Welcome to hell.
So, um we finished Dante's Inferno
today.
And so, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you the overview of how
Dante constructs hell, the Inferno.
And I'll explain to you his reasoning
for the structure. So, um first thing
I'm going to do is explain to you uh
Dante's cosmology, how he understands
God and our relationship with God.
So, um God
in Dante is really the monad of Plato,
okay?
Um
for Plato
God, or the monad, is
eternal,
perfect,
and immutable.
It is It has always been there. It will
always be there. It is perfect.
And it is It will never ever change.
This creates a problem for the universe,
though.
Because if something is perfect, it
cannot be creative. It lacks an
imagination. If it knows everything,
there's nothing for it to learn. Okay?
So, it lacks an imagination.
But without an imagination, the problem
is the universe cannot expand. It cannot
renew itself. It cannot rejuvenate.
So, to solve this problem, what
God does is create us, okay? Humans.
Because the problem with humans is that
we exist in three different planes,
okay? There is the ethereal,
the spiritual,
and the material.
Okay? So, we're existing in multiple
dimensions.
And [snorts]
when we exist on the material, we have
bodies, right?
And these bodies
create
uh pain and pleasure.
We can also die.
And as a result,
we can sin.
Sin.
Okay? What allows us to sin is free
will.
Why it's important to sin, though, is
that you can now be creative. You can
now take risks. You can now be
imaginative. What's important in this
process is to
redeem yourself, to forgive yourself.
The problem then is, okay,
if we can sin, we can do whatever we
want, how do we know what is good and
what is evil?
And the solution to this is this.
Because when God created us, okay, he
breathed into us
life. That's what it says in the Bible.
Therefore, there is a spark in us that
is divine.
Okay? So, we're humans, and there's a
spark in us that is divine.
All right? I'm sorry for the bad
drawing, okay? I'm not an artist. But
there's a spark in us that's divine, and
it is called love.
So, God is love.
And when we love, the spark in us
awakens and it and it
grows. So, how does this thing
grow and glow? The answer is we love
someone else, okay?
All right? Because
the thing about the spark is that it
wants to return to the source.
Okay?
It wants to return to God, and that's
what drives us. This eternal compulsion
to return to the source of who we are,
even though we've forgotten who we are.
Okay? So, the way to do this is we
cannot return to the source in our
world, but we can love someone else.
Not money, not our pet, not a computer,
but someone else. It has to be someone
else because only in someone else is
another spark.
Okay?
So, we're drawn to the spark.
And [snorts] this is really important.
When you love someone else, that person
doesn't have to love you back, okay?
Because love is about giving. It is
giving.
And someone else should receive.
Okay? So, when a mother loves a child,
it doesn't matter the child loves her
back. All that matters is that she loves
him or her unconditionally.
And when that happens, when when that
happens,
the spark in us glows. When it glows, it
reconnects back to the source.
All right? So, the moment we choose to
love someone unconditionally, this this
glows and it grows and returns us to the
source. What happens now is this. It's
really powerful is that
when this happens,
our understanding
of the universe expands.
Because now our view, it's more cosmic.
It's more global than before. We leave
ourselves and we enter into the
universe.
And this is what empowers the
imagination.
Okay?
So, this is how Dante understands
our purpose,
why we're here, where we came from,
where we're going.
It is so that we can
so that our compulsion, our will and
desire,
it is always
to return to the source. To do so, we
have to love someone else, okay?
But in the process of loving else, love
Let me say someone else. This expands
our imagination.
And so, this sounds all a bit confusing,
right? So, let's go back and talk about
the Odyssey.
All right, the Odyssey.
The Odyssey The Odyssey is
a epic poem about a family, right?
Odysseus,
Penelope, and Telemachus.
Odysseus has
left Penelope,
and they're heartbroken. They long to
return to each other, okay? They long to
return to each other. In During the
Trojan War, Odysseus becomes traumatized
by the horrors of war. Remember how he
constructs the Trojan horse?
But And he constructs the Trojan horse
in order to return to Penelope, right?
It's his love for Penelope that expands
his imagination, that allows him to
conceive of the Trojan horse.
The Trojan horse allows the Greeks to
destroy Troy, but it traumatizes
Odysseus because he sees himself how
terrible war is. He came to war He came
to Troy in order to restore a family,
right? To restore Menelaus and Helen.
But with the Trojan horse, he sees that
No, this is destroying families because
the Trojans are being killed and their
wives are being enslaved.
And this traumatizes him. It breaks him
apart. And it's And it splits him from
Penelope.
But he longs to return to Penelope, and
in the process, their love for each
other, once they combine, once they bind
each other, it expands his imagination.
And by expanding his imagination, it
allows him to heal himself.
All right?
Okay? So, this is the dynamic at work.
What's amazing about this is the Odyssey
was written by Homer, and this is
written by Dante.
What's amazing about what happened is
that Dante never read Homer. He read
Virgil.
Because Dante can read Latin. He can't
read Greek.
So, he doesn't have access to the Iliad
and the Odyssey. He doesn't actually
know what Homer wrote and said.
But working independently, they were
able to come to the same framework
understanding of how the universe works.
Okay, that's pretty
uh amazing. All right? All right. So,
this is the cosmology of Dante. Now,
there's certain problems with this,
okay?
The certain The problem is this.
The spark
seeks to
love another spark so that
the spark can return to the source.
Okay, which is God, the monad. In this
process,
once the Once you truly love someone,
your imagination imagination expands,
right? And when your imagination
expands,
the universe itself expands.
And this is how and why we were created,
to expand the universe. Because God
cannot imagine. Only we can imagine.
Because we can feel pain. Because we can
sin. Because we can forgive each other.
But there's there's a problem with this
framework, okay? The problem The problem
is this.
>> [snorts]
>> Sometimes
we cannot love
someone else, okay? Sometimes our soul
cannot expand outwards. It's trapped
inside of us.
Why?
The answer is because we've sinned so
much, okay? The sin is so much that the
that we cannot forgive each other.
Okay? We cannot forgive ourselves. We We
cannot forgive each other.
And so we become trapped in
who we are. We cannot expand outwards.
Therefore, we become distant from the
source. Okay? So, rather than moving
upwards
to the source, which is heaven, we move
downwards into our own hell.
Okay?
So, in other words, heaven and hell are
construction of our own imaginations.
They are the consequences of the of our
emotional state.
We have free will
and we should choose
to love someone else because that's what
that's what brings us back to source.
But sometimes we don't know that and we
commit so much sin that we don't think
we're worthy
of the source. We're not worthy of God
and therefore we create hell to imprison
ourselves in.
And again, this sounds confusing,
but let's use the example of the Iliad.
Right?
>> [snorts]
>> The Iliad.
The Iliad is
Achilles.
He wants to be a hero, but he gets into
a fight with Menelaus. Oh, sorry. Not
Menelaus. Agamemnon. Okay? And then
Okay, let's say "Screw you. You need me
because I'm the best warrior and if you
don't beg me to return, I'll let the
Trojans kill you."
Agamemnon refused to beg. Achilles is in
a lot of trouble, so he sends Patroclus
to die. Right?
And then
Achilles jumps in the battle, kills
Hector, and now, once this is done,
Achilles is trapped in his own guilt.
Right? And
rather than feeling elation, joy in
being the best warrior in the world, he
instead descends in his own hell. He's
trapped in his own hell. And it's only
when Priam
forgives him that he's able to forgive
himself.
And then he's able to restore himself.
All right?
Okay, so there's two
two dimensions at work. When you love
someone, when you do good,
you
ascend to the source, your imagination
expands, the universe expands.
But when you commit sin and the sin is
so bad that you're not able to forgive
yourself,
then you trap yourself in hell and you
are there for all of eternity.
Okay?
And
what's really important to understand is
that
space and time
are constructs of our imagination.
So, in other words, even as we're
speaking now, all right? Our souls are
also living in eternity.
So, the moment we commit a sin,
we imagine ourselves in a certain place
in hell.
And we could be there for all eternity
unless we in our life choose to redeem
ourselves.
No one can redeem us. Only we can redeem
ourselves for our imagination and for
our love. Okay, does that make sense?
All right.
So, um
for
Dante,
what he's going to show
uh he's going to tell us this much
later, okay? But in Inferno, he's going
to construct
uh the structure of hell.
All right. So, what is hell?
So, in hell, there are different layers,
okay? Different circles.
And obviously, the lower you go,
>> [snorts]
>> the greater the punishment, the greater
the sin.
All right. And at the very bottom, the
center of hell is this. This is is um
Dante's word for for Satan or Lucifer,
okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Now,
um
what's happening is that the sin
is greater
W- The reason why is we are less capable
of engaging in self-forgiveness.
All right. So, it's not that others
refuse to forgive us. It's that we
refuse to forgive ourselves.
Okay? Why? Because
we become distant from
um
God.
All right. And
the worse the lower you go in hell, it's
because
not only are you moving away from God,
but you're forcing others to move away
from God as well.
All right?
So,
um here at this level, it's really about
trapping yourself in hell.
But the lower you go, the more people
you trap in hell and the longer you trap
them in hell for.
So, the worst crime, the worst sin in
Dante's world, is treachery.
Okay?
Why?
Because think of um
Achilles and Patroclus. In many ways,
Achilles betrays Patroclus.
Right?
And as a result, Achilles feels guilt
for betraying Patroclus. And if If you
remember the Iliad, he remembers
Patroclus is a ghost that's haunting
him.
All right. So, treachery is the worst
sin because you trap yourself in hell as
well as others.
Um then you have like fraud,
deception.
Okay?
So, what you're doing is you're you are
reducing the capacity of others to love.
Right? So, if I lie to you,
you want to lie to other people as well.
That's just human nature.
When you lie to other people, you cannot
engage in love. You cannot engage in
giving yourself to others. You become
insecure. You become broken. Right? Same
with fraud. When you cheat others,
others are going to want to cheat others
as well. It's almost like a virus.
All right.
>> [snorts]
>> So, those who are in hell are because
they're spreading a virus of deception,
of hatred, of betrayal, which spreads
all around the world, diminishing
people's connection to God, diminishing
people's capacity to love.
W- In heaven, we'll find the opposite,
where people are in heaven because they
choose to love unconditionally,
which spreads God all around the world.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys? All right.
So, let's look at at at specifically at
the construction of hell.
Okay. So,
this is
a schematic of how hell is constructed,
okay? So, remember how how we said that
in the first circle of hell, it's called
limbo.
In limbo, it's kind of nice, okay? It's
like here, but people live forever. And
these people did nothing wrong. They did
actually nothing wrong,
but they were born before the time of
Jesus.
And therefore, people were not aware
um of God. Okay? And these people
include Julius Caesar.
Okay? So, Julius Caesar is in limbo
along other great historical figures.
Then we go into people who have
committed sin, including lust, okay? So,
remember people who committed lust are
people who like Dido and Cleopatra. And
their punishment is they just
um
they're just stuck in a whirlwind. And
so they're they are
moving around hell. They're being swept
by the wind.
And you think about it, this is actually
a very appropriate punishment for lust,
right? Because lust means that you are
swept away by emotions. You are swept
away by your lust for that person. You
cannot control your emotions.
And so, what their punishment in hell is
is just being whipped around in a
whirlwind, okay? And the purpose So, the
purpose of hell is to force you to
engage in reflection.
Because remember,
the universe is governed by free will.
So, people are are in hell not because
they did something wrong, but because
they choose to be there because they
thought they deserved to be there.
All right. So, the punish Every
punishment is constructed in a way that
forces people to see the errors of their
ways and to want to reform.
But you don't have to.
Okay? And um then you have gluttony.
And gluttony is basically
overindulgence. You want too much. And
so, if you remember the punishment for
for overindulgence overindulgence
gluttony, it's rain.
Right?
And it's like a rain that never stops.
And that's a that's a pretty fitting
punishment for gluttony where you have
you like food and you don't want to
stop, right? So, it's almost like rain
raining on you and it can never stop.
Okay? So, then again, the purpose is to
force you to see
um the error of your ways, to see the
limitations of your sin, and to want to
reform.
All right? And then
um
um then we get into the worst circle.
And here, this is basically
um self sin, okay? Meaning sin that only
impacts you. Now, we get to the sin that
impacts others, okay? So,
um here it's violence.
Then you go to fraud. Then the very
worst is treachery.
Okay?
And um
this is how hell is constructed. All
right.
So,
I want to talk about the two bottom
circles of hell. Traitors
to
guests and friends and traitors to
God.
Okay? So, treachery is a really
important concept in The Divine Comedy
because treachery is is the worst way to
condemn people away from God.
All right? And what Dante says is that
there are
um four different types of treachery and
each is worse than the other.
The first type of treachery betrayal is
when you betray your family.
And for Dante, this is actually the
least
um problematic of all betrayals because
you're born into a family. You don't
actually choose
to
uh be part of family, okay? It's
involuntary.
And as such, when we betray someone,
it's it's it's bad, but it's not as bad
as if you choose betray betray if you
choose to go into a bond with someone
and then betray that person.
Okay?
All right? So, that's why traitors to
guests and friends are the worst because
these are bonds created by free will and
trust. And so, you're destroying the
person's capacity to trust other people,
which destroys that person's capacity to
love other people. All right? So, um
the example that Dante uses is this
person
uh Count Ugolino, okay? Count Ugolino.
Count Ugolino.
And he's actually a real person. So,
remember how Dante was participating in
these political wars in Italy?
Well, from his from his perspective, the
worst culprit was Count Ugolino, who was
the head of Pisa. He comes from a
prominent family and he's power crazy.
So, what he does is he betrays everyone
in order to obtain power. And then
finally, he was betrayed by one of his
friends, an archbishop.
And this archbishop betrays
um Count Ugolino and throws him in the
prison along with his children and he
throws away the key so that they starve
to death together. Okay?
And when Dante and Virgil encounter
Count Ugolino, he is biting the head of
the archbishop. They're stuck in a
frozen lake
to represent all of eternity to
represent um immutability
the incapacity to change, and this is
happening over and over where
um Count Ugolino is biting the head of
the archbishop. Now, if you think about
it, this is an analogy to Achilles
mutilating the body of Hector. Right?
Remember in the um Iliad?
Achilles kills Hector in the battle and
at this point, he should return Hector's
body for ransom to the Trojans so the
Trojans can bury him. But instead,
Achilles spends all his time just
mutilating Hector's body.
Achilles feels guilt and sorrow for the
loss of his friend Patroclus. He takes
it out on Hector.
Okay? By mutilating Hector's body. The
same dynamic is happening here where
Count Ugolino blames the archbishop for
the death of his family.
Okay?
Uh but he in his heart knows it's not
the archbishop that killed his children.
It was him himself who condemned his
children because he constantly engaged
in the pursuit of power.
When you engage in the pursuit of power,
you move away from love. You lose the
capacity to love your children and so,
you condemn your children to hell and to
death.
Okay? So, it's this self-hatred
that drives his hatred of the
archbishop. So, it's a very similar
dynamic
as the Iliad. And what Homer says and
what Dante says is the same thing, which
is
betraying others
condemns you to betraying everyone,
including your own children.
And it and that
um
makes you hate yourself so much that you
burn with self-hatred for all of
eternity.
Okay? You are now the most imprisoned in
hell because of your self-hatred. Okay?
Does that make sense, guys? All right.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to read um this part
um
from The Divine Comedy. And so, the
story is again, uh Count Ugolino, he's
always engaged in power politics. He's
always engaged engaging betrayal,
including betrayal of his own people in
Pisa.
Eventually, the people of Pisa get
really angry at him and they overthrow
him led by the archbishop. He's thrown
into prison.
His children also put in the prison with
him. And the archbishop throws away the
key. So, they're just left to starve.
As they're starving,
it is implied that Count Ugolino, he
eats his own children. Okay? And that's
a metaphor for what betrayal is.
Because when you betray someone, you're
cannibalizing that person's soul.
Okay? And you are cannibalizing the soul
of everyone around you.
All right? So, this is just a story told
by Count Ugolino to Dante who's asking
him, "Why are you here?"
Okay? Back to you.
They were awake by now. Okay? They were
my my sons, okay? Like my four sons.
Okay? So, again, he's stuck in prison.
They threw away the key.
And he's stuck there with his four young
sons.
The hour drew near it at which our food
was usually brought and each because of
what he drowned dreamed was anxious.
Below, I heard them
Sorry, I really can't see what's on the
screen.
>> Nailing. Nailing up the door of that
appalling tower. Without a word, I
looked into the faces of my sons.
I did not weep. Within, I turned to
stone.
They wept and my poor little
Anselm. Anselm said, "Father, you look
so
What is wrong with you?"
At that, I shed no tears and all day
long and through the night that
followed, did not answer until another
sun had touched the world.
As soon as a thin ray had made its way
into that sorry prison and I saw
reflected in four faces my own gaze, out
of my grief, I bit at both my hands. And
they, who thought I'd done that out of
hunger, immediately rose and told me,
"Father, it would be far less painful
for us if you ate of us.
For you clothed us in this sad flesh. It
is for you to strip it off." Okay.
[snorts] All right. So,
um the count, he's hungry. He knows he's
at fault for condemning his entire
family to death.
But he cannot bring himself to admit
this. And he becomes very anxious and he
starts biting himself because he's so
afraid of what will happen to his sons.
His sons see this and they feel pity for
him and say, "Are you hungry?"
And he can't answer. So, they basically
said to him, "You know what? It's better
for you to eat us
than
for us to see you starve."
All right? So, the sons are
demonstrating a last act of love for
their father. And because the man he has
betrayed so many people and he can only
see the world in terms of betrayal, he
doesn't recognize this act of love. He's
confused by it and he's desperate to
feed himself. So, he he actually eats
his sons.
Okay?
And so, that's what that's why treachery
is so devastating because it blinds you
to
the possibility of love. Okay? It denies
you the possibility of love. And it and
it lets you commit the most evil because
you refuse to believe that love exists.
Okay?
All right. Now, okay? This is the most
interesting part where we are now at the
very bottom of hell. We've entered the
very center of hell. And so, this is the
place for the worst people. And so,
there are four people in the very center
of hell. There's this Satan Lucifer,
okay? The man the angel who betrayed God
and who who was condemned to hell. And
then, he's biting three individuals who
betrayed God. He's He is biting, chewing
on Judas Iscariot who betrayed Jesus.
That makes sense. The other people don't
actually make any sense. They are
Cassius and Brutus.
And I'll explain to you why it doesn't
really make sense later, okay? But
can you read Ivory?
You can skip this part. This is Latin.
Okay. Um But basically the the king of
God No, sorry. The the king of hell is
before us.
Toward us and therefore keep your eyes
ahead, my master said, to see if you can
spy him.
Just as when night falls on our
hemisphere or when a heavy fog is
blowing thick, a windmill seems to wheel
when seen far off. So then I seem to see
that sort of structure.
And next, because the wind was strong, I
shrank behind my guide. There was no
other shelter.
And now, with fear, I sit it down in
in meter.
I was where all the shades were fully
covered but visible as swifts of straw
and glass.
There are some lie flat and others stand
erect, one on his head and one upon his
his souls.
And some bend face to feet, just like a
bow.
But after we had made our way ahead, my
master felt he now should have should
have me see that creature who was once a
handsome presence. He stepped aside and
made me stop and said, "Look, here's
this and this is the place and this is
the place where you will have to arm
yourself with fortitude."
>> when they meet this, the thing that they
discover is that this is mechanical.
He's a machine.
He doesn't have ideas. He doesn't have
words. He doesn't have free will. He
doesn't have will and desire.
This is what happens when you fully
remove yourself from God. Okay? You lose
the capacity
to be organic. You become a machine. You
just do what you do. So in So this is
almost like an air conditioner, okay?
So what he's doing is he's always
flapping his wings
and then these wings kick the winds of
the frozen lake and then basically make
hell more cool, okay? Cools hell down.
But this lacks agency, lacks ideas,
lacks everything, okay? So it's just a
machine now.
And this
uh Satan, Lucifer, is three heads and on
each head are biting three people.
Okay?
Um the first is, of course, Judas
Iscariot who betrayed Jesus. And again,
this makes perfect sense. But you have
Brutus and Cassius. And Brutus and
Cassius are the ones who betrayed Julius
Caesar.
Okay? So if we just extend the logic,
you would say, "Okay, well, if Jesus was
betrayed by Judas Iscariot and Jesus is
God
and Brutus and Cassius betrayed
Julius Caesar, therefore Julius Caesar
should be God as well, right? Therefore,
Julius Caesar should be in heaven." But
he's not in heaven. He's in limbo. This
makes no sense.
Okay? This is a paradox. And again,
Dante does this a lot where
he
creates
these paradoxes for you to think that
maybe everything I'm seeing is not real.
Maybe this reality it's being created
for me by a stronger power, okay? So the
question then is, who would think of
putting Brutus and Cassius into hell?
Now that person, of course, would be
Virgil.
Okay? And this gives us another clue
that maybe
it's Virgil who's master of hell and not
Lucifer Satan.
Because Lucifer and Satan don't have
agency. They have no imagination. They
don't actually speak or think. They're
just a machine.
Whereas Virgil is the one who's
navigating and negotiating hell
and maybe he wants to put Brutus and
Cassius
into
hell because Virgil's master, of course,
is Augustus Caesar.
Right?
And Augustus Caesar, his father is
Julius Caesar. And in fact, Augustus
Caesar
um made Julius Caesar God of his time.
Okay? So if you just assume this
logically, it doesn't make any sense
if
um we just think that everything is as
it as it seems.
All right? Now, what's going to happen
is that
>> [snorts]
>> um
they're going to climb
Lucifer and escape hell and now they're
in purgatory.
All right? They've left hell, now
they're in purgatory. And this is the
first first stanza of Sorry, not the
first stanza. But when they go to
purgatory, and purgatory is actually a
mountain.
Okay?
And they're going to climb the mountain
so that they can ascend ultimately to
heaven.
But on the shores of purgatory, they
meet the guardian
of purgatory. And this guardian is named
Cato.
Who is Cato?
Cato, along with Brutus and Cassius,
opposed
um Julius Caesar. At this time, Julius
Caesar was amassing power for himself in
Rome. There were a lot of people who
opposed Julius Caesar,
including Ptolemy
um and including Cato.
Cato chose to kill himself rather than
submit to Julius Caesar.
But this makes no sense because first of
all, okay?
Cato
was born
before Jesus.
Does that make sense?
He was born before Jesus. And Virgil
told us that if you're born before
Jesus, the best place you can hope for
is limbo. That's it. But Cato is in
purgatory, which is which is better than
hell. Not only that, but he's the master
and guardian of purgatory. That makes no
sense. That's point one.
Point two is
he killed himself.
This is a sin.
Okay? This is a crime.
You should be in hell for that.
Why is he in purgatory?
The third thing is he betrayed
Caesar.
Okay? Or opposed
Cassius and Brutus also betrayed and
opposed Caesar and they are
burning in hell.
Right?
So again, this is a paradox. And it
forces us
to
think about what's really going on here.
All right? Um so can you read um
Ivory?
I saw a solitary patriarch near me. His
aspect worthy of such reverence that
even son to father owes no more.
His beard was long and mixed with white
as were the hairs upon his head and his
hair spread down to his chest in the
divided tress.
The rays of the four holy stars so
framed his face with light that in my
sight he seemed like one who is
confronted by the sun.
"Who are you who, against the hidden
river, were able to escape the the
eternal prison?"
He said, moving those venerable plumes.
"Who is your guide? What serves you both
as lantern when, from the deep night
that will always keep the hellish valley
dark, you were set free?
The laws of the abyss, have they been
broken or has a new change a changed
decree in heaven let you, so damned,
approach my rocky slopes?"
>> this is Cato, okay? Again, Cato is the
guardian of purgatory. So he sees Dante
and Virgil marching. He's like, "What
are you guys doing here? This is This
goes against the laws of the universe.
You should not be able to break free of
hell."
>> [snorts]
>> All right. Can Can you read again?
My guide took hold of me decisively by
way of words and bends and other signs.
He made my knees and brows show
reverence.
Then he replied, "I do not come through
my own self. There was a lady sent from
heaven. Her pleas led me to help and
guide this man.
But since your will would have a far
more full and accurate account of our
condition,
my will cannot withhold what you
request.
This man had yet to set see his final
evening,
but through his fully fully little time
was left before he did, he was so close
to it.
As I have told you, I was sent to him
for his deliverance. The only road I
could have taken was the road I took.
I showed him all the people of
perdition. Now I intend to show to him
those spirits who,
in your care, are bent on
expiation. expiation.
"To tell you how I led him would take
long. It is a power descending from
above that helped me guide him here here
to see and hear you." Okay. So what's
happening here is Cato's like, "What are
you guys doing here?" And Virgil steps
up and tries to explain what's going on.
Now, what's interesting is that Cato and
Virgil know each other. They were born
and they lived around the same time in
Rome, okay? And they were in limbo
together. So they know each other really
well, but Virgil is being very polite to
him. He's being He's almost afraid of
Cato, okay?
All right.
Keep on reading, Ivory.
"Now may it please you to his coming. He
goes in search of liberty, so precious
and as he who gives his life for it must
know.
You know it, who in Utica found death
>> Okay, so he killed himself in Utica,
okay?
Found death for freedom was not bitter
when you left the garb that will be
bright on the great day.
>> Okay, so he killed himself because he
would rather die honorably than to
submit himself as a slave to Caesar. So,
what Virgil is saying is like, you died
a noble death even though suicide is
considered a sin in the Catholic Church.
Okay, keep on going.
Eternal edicts are not broken for us.
This man's alive and I'm not bound by
Minos, but I am from the circle where
the chaste eyes of your Marcia are and
she still prays to you, oh holy priest
breast, to keep her as your own for her
love. Then incline to us.
Allow our journey through your seven
realms. I shall thank for her for
kindness you bestow if you would let
your name be named below. Okay, all
right. This is really interesting, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> What he's saying is and Virgil is being
very subtle, right? He's saying to Cato,
"Listen, your wife Marcia, he's she's
still in limbo with me.
And if you treat us well here, I'll go
back to limbo and treat Marcia really
nice."
Okay, it's almost like a bribe. All
right, it's almost like a small threat
to Cato.
Okay? All right, keep on reading.
While I was there within the other
world, Marcia so pleased my eyes. He
then replied, "Each kindness she
required I satisfied."
>> Wow, this is really interesting, okay?
While within the other world. So, what
he's saying is that before I was in
limbo with you, Virgil, and my wife
Marcia.
Okay? He's saying that. But remember,
when we first read Inferno, Virgil told
us that, "Listen, if you're born before
the time of Jesus, you're stuck in
limbo. This is the best place you can
hope for."
But maybe there are certain people who
are so glorious
and they're so such part of the biblical
tradition that when Jesus came to hell,
he took them to heaven, including people
like Abraham,
Isaac,
uh his father Joseph,
Mary, okay? David. These people who are
in the Bible and who are part of the
Christian tradition, Jesus took with
him. But everyone else is stuck in
limbo.
But he's saying, "Cato, while you're not
a Christian,
you killed yourself, you were with us in
limbo,
but you were able to ascend to purgatory
while your wife Marcia was still left
behind."
Okay? This is like a paradox.
Okay, keep on going.
Now that she dwells beyond the evil
river, she has no power to move me any
longer.
Such was the law decreed when I was
freed.
But if a lady come from heaven speaks in
hell's mouth
>> okay, all right.
So, what he's what he's he's saying is
before I loved Marcia. [clears throat]
But after I was freed and I escaped
limbo and I now am in purgatory, I no I
no longer love her, but I don't respect
her. We can we can ask specifically as
to why.
Okay? This is really strange because I
already told you in the beginning that
what love is giving to other people,
right?
So, in purgatory,
if Cato really loved Marcia, then he
should be thinking about scheming as to
how to bring Marcia to to purgatory,
right?
That that's what makes sense.
If you
make a lot of money, then you want to
share this money with with your with the
people you love, right?
But again, this is where Dante is
different because
what is the most important thing is free
will.
If you truly love someone, you let that
person choose. You don't force that
person do anything [music] against his
or her free will.
Okay? So, I Cato, I chose to come to
purgatory
because I willed it. I desired it.
Therefore, God let me come.
I was able to find
the will and desire
to self-reflect, to forgive myself, and
to come to purgatory. Marcia did not,
but I cannot make her
self-reflect. She has to choose to do so
by on her own.
Okay?
So, because as long as she's there, I
have to let her be there.
And
my love for her won't change anything.
So, I choose to focus on other things.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right, it does you no good
to force anyone to do anything. That's
not what love is.
All right.
Keep on reading.
As you say, there is no need of
flattery. It is not indeed to ask me for
her sake.
Go then, but first wind a smooth rush
around his waist and bathe his face to
wash away all of hell's stains. For it
would not be seemly to approach with
eyes still dimmed by any mists.
The first
custodian angel, one from paradise.
This solitary island, all around its
very base, there where the breakers
the breakers pound, bare rush
on the soft and muddy ground.
There is no other plant that looks
below, no plant with leaves or plant
that as it grows hardens and breaks
beneath the waves' harsh blows.
That done, do not return by the same
path. The sun, which rises now, will
show you how this hillside can be
climbed more easily.
With that, he vanished and without a
word, I rose and drew in closer to my
guide and it was on him I set my eyes.
>> Okay, all right. So, they're now in
purgatory, okay? And and what Cato is
saying is that purgatory is a mountain.
They have to climb the mountain to reach
heaven, but purgatory is a mountain that
is enclosed, okay? So, waves, wind
cannot touch this
um mountain.
All right, and so uh we now are in
purgatory and I want you to finish
purgatory
uh
or try to read as much as you can.
Um and and we'll continue this next
week. Are there any questions
about this?
Okay? So, again,
this is a journal journey undertaken by
Dante,
okay, into the cosmos.
And he's taking us taking us with him.
What's really interesting about Dante is
he he appreciates that for us to
understand, we first have to
misunderstand, okay? It's
misunderstanding
>> [snorts]
>> that leads to understanding.
We have to correct ourselves in order to
fully understand the truth.
What he also believes is that for us to
be virtuous, we first must have to sin.
Okay? It's okay to sin because it allows
us to recognize our limitations
and then makes us much more virtuous.
And it's and it's this process
that drives the imagination.
Does [snorts] that make sense?
If you want to understand, you first
have to misunderstand. If you want to be
virtuous, you must first sin.
Okay?
Any questions?
All right, okay. So, so we'll we'll
we'll we'll continue this next week,
okay?
Okay? So, again,
this is a journal journey
Dante.
Okay, into the cosmos.
And he's taking us taking us with him.
What's really interesting about Dante is
he he appreciates that for us to
understand, we first have to
misunderstand, okay? It's
misunderstanding
that leads to understanding.
We have to correct ourselves in order to
fully understand the truth.
What he also believes is that for us to
be virtuous, we first must have to sin.
Okay? It's okay to sin because it allows
us to recognize our limitations
and then makes us much more virtuous.
And it's and it's this process
that drives the imagination.
Does that make sense?
If you want to understand, you first
have to misunderstand. If you want to be
virtuous, you must first sin.
Okay?
Any questions?